wawk wawk I'm ready for game play let's
go
how's it going bros my name is Peter Pat
welcome back to part two of quantum
break this game is something this game
looks so real it's so cool and I'm
really enjoying playing this for you if
you haven't heard about the game yet
well you're about to find out
alright this is where we left on I
killed all these [ __ ] um there we go
just keep spraying keep spraying baby
hey I see you through the bookshelf yeah
deck whose nope let me reload let me
reload that's it baby that's it baby the
bookshelf cover mate not a good idea
so right now you may think hey this just
looks like an ordinary shooter but no
the guy from Lord of the Rings is in it
look at him he's beautiful
we can't go to your car mara could be
expecting that we have to Jack it's
important to fix the fracture I I need
we need to get to my car we need to get
to your card why what's important ok
times broken fine but now you're saying
we can fix it in theory I built
something for such an event years ago
look it looks like they're kissing
planning the countermeasure won't be
easy look look there looked a turtle
okay Oh what was that
okay oh god what happened maybe the door
still open let me try let me try what
the door opening skills this guy is
crazy with doors man oh he clicked the
button
hi guys oh [ __ ]
thanks mate oh man he loves me
well so here it is we froze time that's
the cool part about this game what would
you do if you can freeze time freeze
will top comment will get the nice great
frozen star
she was right whoa holy Sh whoa mate
I'll take your gun for that haha I'll
take your gun I wish I could just kick
them in the balls just like all the
movies and then you hit play and they
they go like eh yep
no okay I'm sorry look at this that's so
cool
so pretty this game look at that look at
that oh man you got done [ __ ] what are
you doing then all they're grabbing all
the people the witnesses I knew it
we're gonna help I'll help you Bruce let
me touch you come on baby let me touch
you
that's it that's
put your face on the screen it's gonna
be okay it's not working
yeah you may have to do it
ah of course cronin exposure yeah look
at that helicopter so cool this game is
very impressive it's nice to finally see
next-gen titles looking good you know
what I mean I'm winking but you probably
can't see it in case like oh my god they
got the taxi driver what do we got here
we don't know how long he's gonna last
man I'll explain in the car
Hey look at this oh my god are we free I
think we heard it was collapsed for now
indeed no kind of [ __ ] are they studying
patrolling the parking lot oh god that's
it's okay okay will right now okay I'll
take care of this oh ah that's right
I'll get the carnal bring it around you
think I'm wearing these game advice you
can handle this no are you sure you can
fix time darkness no then we'll call it
even
yeah okay this is getting exciting
oh my god anything can happen it's lime
there's also this thing where you like
if you hear it's obvious that we're
gonna follow him but you can also like
go somewhere else and find details look
at this all right well maybe not I don't
know all right
yeah hey Jack be careful oh gosh
yeeeaahhh Drew's gonna kiss me fine I
will
and I ship them harder than Dan and Phil
just kidding that's impossible
okay so I'm just joking by the way um no
I'm not what do you want Oh
press why attractive a time vision to
look at enemies hazard items oh my god
so we see items and enemies all right so
what's the best let's try and sneak up
who are you finna try [ __ ] I am so good
at aiming listen I play PC okay
I'm not used to [ __ ] controller Jesus
crew alright where's the car their
radius I could see an echo of the past
an echo of the past there we go
if you die you get killed a great man
once told me it was me spoilers alright
echo ver the pass that's M that looks
cool he's triangles
Illuminati confirmed all right there we
go in the cart oh my lord well it's a
good thing they suck at aiming for a tap
to cast time stop okay so we're finally
getting like the time stop movement and
[ __ ] I could reach out and stop time in
a [ __ ] is their own [ __ ] they got well
got willow
uh tap okay time stop all right we stop
time for that [ __ ] we're just
gonna run for it baby oh my god oh my
god they're crazy let's take this guy
out
no never mind hey baby every go whoa
that's awesome there it is
time stop or just spray away and that's
how it's done
you're welcome every went screw the car
I need to get the will screw the car
what do you mean screw the car oh my god
oh my God will change his mind will
became a girl what the [ __ ] she's he's a
really nice-looking man where's my
brother
they're taking him to the library you
might still be able to catch them she
looks as this like she's seen us before
it's more complicated than look I don't
know if you can make it but you should
hurry she wears a lot of lip gloss it's
probably gonna be old schmudge it's the
first time you saw Beth Wilder yeah
but definitely not the first time she
saw me hmm she came from the other side
act one part three
alright alright alright as a great man
once said it was me
we'll keep you got a fine well I need to
find become better at this game don't
worry I will get better as time passes
it will be like watching your child
learn how to walk that will be the
experience of watching me play this game
time make us okay where the [ __ ] is
within Jason oh ok these are the
soldiers and she had him I don't even
see them supposed to take William Joyce
alive he doesn't put up a fight fighting
please let me go I can shut the hell up
god damn it Mary okay so they went up
here oh that's cool look at that we we
use time too hey guys what's up
my name is PewDiePie subscribe how the
[ __ ] did I do that
tap to time dodge time dodge holy [ __ ]
that's awesome time dodge of course all
right what do we get you through it time
dodge can you stop
hahaha I love that one it's awesome
mate can you not haha I love it so much
it's so good
yeah told you I'll learn how to walk one
of these days oh god it's a prank it's a
social experiment good thing I filmed it
for YouTube so it's okay alright is this
liquid cafeteria we're playing as
jacksepticeye is at it I knew it that
Irish [ __ ] lovely beautiful
you still had no idea that Wilder was
helping you she wasn't the only one so
the girl is helping is right now how I
don't see it what are their reffering
referencing she's causing a distraction
for us that's cool quiet many issues
it's all being taken care of you heard
the big guy contingency plan as to the
facts I mean finish what we started and
reconvene to the dry docks simple as
that I've got problems of course not
Sarah of course well if I only had like
a [ __ ] silent weapon maybe I could
actually do this now it's pretty pie
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] fat-ass look at this [ __ ]
what you gonna do but you're gonna
[ __ ] do me eat [ __ ] and die
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
let me reload dick shut there you go
whoo salsa this is really fun good old
good old time killing people murdering
people
hope you guys don't have kids ha ha ha
so unnecessary but so satisfying and
you're dead ha ha ha
Hey look at that plate sounds ghostly
whoa goodbye plates [ __ ] books
oh jeez he needs to return some books
that's a sick burn I gotta find a way in
I got to get to a fast
I got to remember that we got a rumor
that burn gotta return some [ __ ]
books [ __ ] we got to find a way in I'm
guessing this doesn't work it's gotta be
another way in this sketch be Anatomy
alright well thanks for telling me game
we go up here we go up here yep and epic
Jam tan never man hey ah well I
convenient we got the time at the slope
yes come on baby
come on Jackie Joo jump oh [ __ ] that was
epic e ok cool I like this down parts
it's very Merce it makes him feel part
of the world good job game
of course the time machine Cora oh hello
oh you just got a pop while that hell is
going on around yeah someone probably
went back in time knew that was gonna
happen and save this that'd be cool
I hope this game has a paradox and it's
always interesting when they incorporate
that in getting stories and one down huh
hi guys
thanks for inviting me to your party
okay let's [ __ ] this guy's oh well sorry
but I love that move so much heavy
pistol ooh
well don't mind if I do baby this is
cool I love that what level design I'm
sure we're gonna come back here later
I'm sure of it
holy goes I'll save you Mary or Pippin
or shiver Frodo
Oh oh my god we can't even get a new
move
yes time shield press B to create a time
shield I love time shields look at night
it's actually just a fart who'd have
thought I wish it was like neo just like
where I know there is a matrix game but
I don't know if he's actually gonna
night all right let's look at the
situation we got [ __ ] to that we can
explode okay let's take this guy at
first
oh man that's awesome hey what are you
doing well that could have gone better
hi guys let's shoot this see what
happens
hey fireworks
Katy Perry called it um I wonder I want
to see explosions in a time stop let's
see how that looks like okay this guy
well that's not exactly what I wanted to
do oh look that's cool you can't say
that that's not cool am i focusing too
much I'm doing cool stuff I'm sorry I'll
kill them last one one more okay okay
let's push this over here now mate come
here come here mate I need you to come
here it's cool oh here we go so now we
shoot that
and that's sort of sent wow it's cool
that how things get destroyed when you
shoot it and that didn't happen you're
fine that's right you're fine don't
worry about it man oh yeah
fired I forgot about it get me out of
here first wear your snail get up man
you have to hearty where's my car I
didn't like to you holler let's get a
new one what no Jack I need them no we
got it you need that specific card good
to go back in time you've only done this
once security not insured okay so I'm
having probably with my webcam I'm sorry
if it cuts off sometimes I know that
bothers people and he bothers me - trust
me I'll take you shopping
shoot the exploding thing pewds Carrodus
Oh
shotgun time she'll shotgun time shield
shout down hey I'm the [ __ ] matrix
guy here don't even try to pull matrix
move on me [ __ ]
even high five you want to spank your
butt is that it see what you're implying
game some kind of BDSM sad words call
whatever it's not like I would know we
have to get to my briefcase then we find
Beth Wilder why who is she she knows
about the fracture I trust her I
wouldn't trust anyone named Beth glad
you trusted somebody don't know no no no
don't trust Beth game knows I kept
secrets from you to keep you safe safe
secrets look around you will does this
feel safe to you this isn't my fault
warned me this would happen did
everything in my power to stop it wait
so Beth has powers too any of this I
couldn't just how long have you know we
don't have time for this now Jack we
have to get to that briefcase alright
alright
breathe Kay's in the car got it let's
get it mmm okay see I totally we come
back show up I told ya I told you this
place is way too pretty to just rush
through you're not having me yeah hi
oh it's the bad guy it's gonna be a epic
showdown I know it Jack we gotta go hon
it's my brother Jack Oh
oh [ __ ] it's his evil twin I knew it
what happened to you what are you doing
only what's necessary think about this
you don't know what's at stake I know
exactly what's at stake that's why I'm
here you believe you can stop what's
coming I'm giving you one chance to
change your mind this path it's already
said it can't be changed the past the
future I've seen I've lived it for 17
years
ooh that's a long 10 teen years it was
you the first experiment come with me
and we can see this through or hold onto
your hope and burn with it now listen I
built the device I can stop this I can
you can't madness there's no harm in
trying
there is that's why I can't risk you
opposing me will it doesn't have to win
like this so the one with the gun you
just let this happen I'll never stop
trying he's too cute not yet years to
come to terms of what must be done but
we don't have years wait wait wait wait
what used to fart
trigger
where's that mean I never wanted this
job
oh [ __ ] no the Jack died I mean Paul I
mean it will end of act 1 whoo that's
cool that's real cool make me want to
dance yeah we did it
act 1 baby what a start what a start oh
boy am I excited I'm shaking this is not
jazz hands let me tell you oh you got
him - you got the Jess you got the jazz
hands
continue oh boy oh boy oh boy
quite quantum break junction one hard
line / PR ok so I'll end up so dear
Bruce thank you so much for watching and
let me know if you want more I would
love to do more and your likes and your
comments are really help to support the
show it makes me understand if you liked
it or not and yeah it's pretty cool I'm
really excited to play this game for you
and yeah I'll see you the next part as
always thank you so much for watching